hustle con this year that guy Eric Ryan
talked about the confounder a method
soap and Ollie and well lead all these
great d2c brands or sort of not DS he
actually just new consumer brands that
they sell through Target and whatnot you
know he said a line that stuck with me
does the number one most important thing
from hazak on this year in my opinion he
goes you have to identify the culture
shift first and you know the culture
shift happens first and then the
products and services that that meet
those cultural values come second so
let's say four methods soap he was
saying you know consumers now they turn
their everything they buy they turn to
the back and they read the ingredients
and so they care about what they're
putting in their body they care about
what they're putting in their homes they
care about what they're putting in their
babies but cetera et cetera and so you
see honest company take off because
people care about what they're putting
on their baby
you see native deodorant take off
because people care about putting
natural ingredients and not aluminum and
parabens you know in their armpits and
methods soap took off because they said
hey you shouldn't have to clean your
house to toxic chemicals but he
identified the culture shift first now I
don't know how much of this is just
retro speak because entrepreneurs do do
that where they just make up a story
later about how they did it and the real
reason was just some total numerical
thing where they were like oh yeah I
just so we know firsthand this was true
with Moyes with native deodorant that he
did this yeah and he actually tweeted
today some more info which I thought was
good he said he identified that natural
deuteron was one of the top sell
anything he's at number one I don't know
if it's actually number one but it was
one of the top selling products on Etsy
period yeah but everybody was buying it
out of a jar and you had to like do this
weird thing stick her hand on the jar
then rub it in your armpit and he's like
look people want people want natural
deodorant but they want the convenience
of the stick if I could figure out how
to put natural deodorant in a stick I
think I can make a business that works
and you know 18 months later sells it
for a hundred million dollars so I think
there's something to identifying the
culture shift and if the culture shift
is hey we gotta like hunker down a
little bit or hey we gotta like
supporter local businesses like small
businesses that's where something like a
Groupon or a Groupon 2.0 is very very
interesting to me
very hard to pull off extremely hard to
pull off because local is super super
hard and slow to scale and you're
dealing with long I'm at bomb and pop
style businesses but Groupon was not
slow to scale Groupon got to a billion
dollars in sales i I think faster than
any other company ever now it's true
that she didn't it didn't operate well
it was now there didn't say I don't want
to talk out my ass no I think it did
stick I mean look up until recently
Groupon hey I look up how much does
Groupon do in revenue they still well it
didn't stick from a merchant perspective
what happened was they on bordered all
these merchants the merchants to win on
and they would get a bunch of empty
traffic and then those empty sort of
calories eventually they pulled off and
they said why am i offering these deals
people come did they take the sale they
don't come back and that part didn't
work so they lost on the merchant side
for a while and then they got all these
clones came out that were doing the
exact same thing so customers sort of
got inundated with daily deals products
so that was a bit of the problem there
but you're right actually they did scale
very fast
[Music]